Une énorme révolution du shopping se produit en Chine actuellement.
Les comportements d’achats et les plateformes technologiques
ont évolué différemment de partout ailleurs dans le monde.
Par exemple, le e-commerce est en très forte hausse en Chine.
Il grandit deux fois plus vite qu’aux États-Unis
et beaucoup de sa croissance vient du mobile.
Chaque mois, 500 millions de consommateurs
achètent sur leurs téléphones mobiles.
Pour replacer dans le contexte,
c’est l’équivalent de toute la population des États-Unis,
du Royaume-Uni et de l’Allemagne combinés.
Mais ce n’est pas que l’échelle du e-commerce,
c’est la vitesse d’adoption et l’intégration des écosystèmes.
La Chine a mis moins de cinq ans à devenir un pays du commerce connecté
et c’est surtout grâce à deux plateformes technologiques :
Alibaba et Tencent.
Ils détiennent 90% du e-commerce -
presque l’ensemble du marché -
85% des médias sociaux,
85% du paiement en ligne.
Ils ont aussi de grandes parts dans le contenu digital, la vidéo, le streaming,
la littérature, l’information de voyage, le jeu vidéo.
Quand cette énorme base de consommateurs connectés
rencontre ces écosystèmes intégrés,
des réactions chimiques ont lieu.
Aujourd’hui, la Chine est comme un énorme laboratoire
générant toutes sortes d’expérimentations.
Vous devriez venir en Chine,
pour y voir un aperçu du futur.
Une des tendances que j’ai observées porte sur la spontanéité du shopping.
Il y a 5 ans, dans une étude sur la mode,
on a découvert qu’en moyenne,
un consommateur chinois achetait de cinq à huit paires de chaussures.
Ce nombre a triplé pour atteindre environ 25 paires par an.
Qui aurait besoin d’autant de chaussures ?
Je leur ai demandé : « Pour quelles raisons achetez-vous ? »
Ils m’ont donné une liste d'influences :
les blogs, l’actualité people, l’actualité de la mode.
Mais, pour beaucoup, il n’y avait pas de raison particulière d’acheter.
Ils étaient en train de naviguer sur leur mobile
et d’acheter tout ce qu’ils voyaient.
On a observé le même niveau de spontanéité partout,
des achats alimentaires à ceux des produits d’assurance.
Mais ce n’est pas très difficile à comprendre si on y pense.
Pour beaucoup de consommateurs chinois, c’est très nouveau
d’avoir un mode de vie de classe moyenne ou de classe moyenne aisée.
Ils ont un fort désir d’acheter tout ce qui est nouveau,
de nouveaux produits et services.
Dans cet écosystème intégré,
c’est tellement facile pour eux d’acheter, un clic après l’autre.
Cependant, ce nouveau comportement d’achat crée beaucoup de défis
pour les entreprises autrefois dominantes.
Le propriétaire d’une entreprise de mode m’a dit être très frustré
car ses clients se plaignent toujours que ses produits ne sont pas assez nouveaux.
Pour une entreprise de mode, c'est un mauvais commentaire.
Il avait déjà augmenté le nombre de produits dans chaque collection.
Ça ne semble pas marcher.
Je lui ai dit qu’il y a quelque chose d’encore plus important.
Il faut donner à votre client exactement ce qu’il veut
quand il le veut encore.
Il peut apprendre des acteurs de l'habillement en Chine.
Ces entreprises collectent les réactions réelles des clients
depuis les app mobiles et les médias sociaux.
Puis leurs designers traduisent cette information
en idées de produits
et ils les envoient à des micro-studios de production.
Ces micro-studios sont vraiment essentiels pour l’écosystème global,
car ils prennent des petites commandes,
30 vêtements à chaque fois
et ils peuvent aussi faire des pièces partiellement customisées.
Comme tous ces designs de production
sont faits localement,
le processus complet, du transport, à un produit en boutique ou en ligne
prend parfois seulement trois ou quatre jours.
C’est super rapide
et très réactif par rapport à ce qui est à la mode sur le marché.
Ça donne d’énormes maux de têtes aux distributeurs traditionnels
qui conçoivent seulement quelques collections dans l’année.
Ainsi, il y a un besoin du consommateur pour le confort extrême.
Il y a quelques mois, je faisais les magasins avec une amie à Tokyo.
On était dans un magasin
et il y avait trois ou quatre personnes devant nous
à la caisse.
Plutôt normal, pas vrai ?
Mais on a tous les deux abandonné notre sélection
et on est partis.
Voici à quel point on est devenus impatients.
Apporter l'ultra-confort n'est pas qu'un atout cosmétique.
C'est crucial pour s'assurer que votre client achète vraiment.
En Chine, nous avons appris
que le confort est vraiment la colle qui fera du shopping en ligne
un comportement et une habitude qui persistera.
C'est parfois plus efficace qu'un programme de fidélité tout seul.
Prenez Hema.
C'est un concept d'épicerie de détail développé par Alibaba.
Ils livrent un panier complet de produits
depuis 4 000 stocks jusqu'à votre porte
en 30 minutes.
Ce qui est incroyable, c'est qu'ils livrent pratiquement de tout :
des fruits, des légumes bien sûr.
Mais aussi du poisson frais
et des crabes royaux d'Alaska vivants.
Comme me le disait une amie une fois :
« Mon rêve devient réalité.
Finalement, je peux impressionner ma belle-mère
quand elle me rend visite pour dîner à l'improviste. »
(Rires)
Des entreprises comme Amazon et FreshDirect
font aussi des tests dans ce domaine.
Le fait que Hema fasse partie de l'écosystème Alibaba
rend les choses plus rapides et un peu plus faciles à mettre en place.
Pour un acteur de l'épicerie en ligne,
c'est très difficile et coûteux
de livrer un panier complet rapidement.
Mais pour Hema, il y a une appli mobile,
un système de paiement mobile
et aussi 20 magasins physiques dans des zones très peuplées de Shanghaï.
Ces magasins sont construits pour garantir la fraîcheur du produit -
ils ont vraiment des aquariums dans le magasin -
et aussi pour avoir des lieux qui permettent une livraison très rapide.
Je sais quelle question vous avez en tête.
Ils font de l'argent ?
Oui, ils font de l'argent.
Ils sont rentables
et ce qui est aussi incroyable, c'est que le chiffre d'affaires par magasin
est trois à quatre fois plus élevé que pour une épicerie traditionnelle
et la moitié du résultat vient des commandes mobiles.
C'est vraiment la preuve que le consommateur,
si on lui donne cet ultra-confort qui marche bien pour l'achat d'aliments,
va modifier ses comportements d'achat en ligne,
en un rien de temps.
L'ultra-confort et la spontanéité,
ce n'est pas absolument tout.
L'autre tendance que j'ai observée en Chine,
c'est le shopping social.
Si on pense au shopping social ailleurs dans le monde,
c'est un processus linéaire.
On détecte quelque chose sur Facebook,
on le regarde et on passe sur Amazon
ou brand.com pour terminer l'expérience d'achat.
Clair et simple.
Mais en Chine, c'est une chose très différente.
En moyenne, un consommateur passe 1 heure sur son portable à faire du shopping.
C'est trois fois plus qu'aux États-Unis.
D'où vient cette forte adhésion ?
Que font-ils vraiment sur ce minuscule écran ?
Suivez-moi dans un parcours de shopping mobile
que je pourrais vivre.
23 heures, c'est en général l'heure où je fais du shopping.
J'avais une discussion sur WeChat avec mes amis.
L'un d'eux a sorti un paquet de snacks
et a posté le lien vers le produit sur ce salon de discussion.
Je déteste ça, car d'habitude, je clique juste sur ce lien
pour atterrir sur la page du produit.
Plein d'informations, très coloré,
époustouflant.
J'ai regardé le produit, alors un vendeur se connecte
et me demande : « En quoi puis-je vous aider ce soir ? »
Bien sûr, j'ai acheté ce paquet de snacks.
Le plus génial c'est que je sais que le lendemain, autour de midi,
ce paquet de snacks sera livré à mon bureau.
Je peux le manger et le partager avec mes collègues
pour un coût de livraison de maximum un dollar.
Juste quand j'allais quitter ce site marchand,
un autre écran est apparu.
Cette fois, c'est le streaming en direct d'une célébrité populaire
qui m'apprend comment porter une nouvelle couleur de rouge à lèvres.
Je l'ai regardée 30 secondes - très facile à comprendre -
et ici aussi il y a un lien pour acheter juste à côté,
j'ai cliqué et je l'ai acheté en quelques secondes.
Retour au salon de discussion.
Les bavardages continuent.
Un autre de mes amis a posté le QR code
d'un autre paquet de snacks.
J'ai cliqué, je l'ai acheté.
Donc, l'expérience globale,
c'est comme d'explorer un parc d'attractions.
C'est chaotique, amusant
et même un peu addictif.
C'est ce qui se passe quand vous avez cet écosystème intégré.
Le shopping est embarqué dans le social,
et le social évolue au sein d'une expérience multidimensionnelle.
L'intégration des écosystèmes atteint un tout nouveau niveau.
Sa domination s'exerce ainsi sur tous les aspects de notre vie.
Évidemment, il y a des opportunités commerciales énormes en toile de fond.
Une entreprise chinoise de snacks, Les Trois Écureuils,
a bâti un empire d'un demi-million de dollars en seulement trois ans
en investissant dans 300 à 500 vendeurs
qui vont apporter des services en ligne 24 heures sur 24, 7 jours sur 7.
Dans l'univers des médias sociaux,
ils sont comme vos voisins.
Même quand vous n'achetez rien,
ils sont contents de vous raconter des blagues, de vous rendre heureux.
Dans cet écosystème intégré,
les médias sociaux peuvent vraiment redéfinir la relation entre la marque,
le vendeur et le consommateur.
Ce ne sont que des fragments des changements massifs
que j'ai observés en Chine.
Dans cet immense laboratoire,
beaucoup d'expériences sont générées chaque jour.
Les écosystèmes modifient
la répartition de la chaîne logistique, le marketing, l'innovation produit,
absolument tout.
Les consommateurs reçoivent le pouvoir de décider ce qu'ils veulent acheter,
quand ils le veulent,
comme ils le veulent, et au niveau de socialisation voulu.
C'est maintenant aux dirigeants d'entreprises dans le monde
d'ouvrir vraiment leurs yeux pour voir ce qu'il se passe en Chine,
d'y penser et de passer à l'action.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Massimo Portincaso : Ce que vous nous avez dit Angela
est impressionnant et quasi incroyable,
mais je pense que beaucoup de gens dans le public ont la même question que moi,
à savoir :
cette forme de consommation impulsive
est-elle durable sur le long terme à la fois économiquement et écologiquement ?
Et quel est le prix total à payer
pour une expérience client aussi automatisée et ultra-confortable ?
Angela Wang : Oui. Nous devons garder une chose à l'esprit.
Nous sommes au tout début d'une transformation immense.
Donc avec ces besoins d'achats plus élevés du consommateur,
combiné à l'évolution de l'écosystème,
il y a beaucoup d'opportunités et aussi de défis.
J'ai ainsi vu des signes précoces
d'un changement d'orientation des écosystèmes
pour prêter attention à la résolution de ces défis.
Par exemple, considérer davantage le développement durable
en même temps que la seule rapidité,
et aussi la qualité à la quantité.
Mais il n'y a pas de réponses très simples à ces questions.
C'est précisément pourquoi je suis ici pour dire à tous
qu'on doit observer, étudier et prendre part à cette évolution.
MP : Merci beaucoup.
AW : Merci.
(Applaudissements)